I'll let you dude I won't take I won't say your moment I won't say this is like
the most of course this is Joel moment that I can possibly think of it's like there's some super
awesome you know niche piece of technology that I'm ready to blow your mind about and you're like
oh yeah I use that for my terminal they're most like a random thing exactly
hey guys real quick I just wanted to tell you about our sponsor Threat Locker now wait wait
before you hit the skip forward button let me just say this most of the stuff that holds my attention
nowadays is Red Team stuff as well but I sat down with the Threat Locker team this past week to do
a demo of their EDR software and it was super technically fascinating how this thing works
so check this out you drop this thing on a system right and for the first week or so it's creating
a policy and a profile for that system it's logging all the executables what child processes are being
spawned the files and their hashes that sort of thing and it's creating this policy okay then after
the learning mode is up we're in secured mode and that policy gets put into place and anything that's
not on that allow list is immediately auto denied that's the zero trust piece right so in addition
to that they've got a bunch of crazy features like ring fencing and dynamic access controls that would
stop a malicious hacker at pretty much every step along the way actually I was watching this demo and I was
kind of freaked out because I have no idea how I would cope with getting dropped into a Threat Locker
system as a Red Teamer anyway if you want to learn more about this head over to threatlocker.com
and request a demo and when you do ask for my boy Andrew his demo was super to the point
and he was able to answer all my technical questions all right cool back to the show
all right dude we're rolling so I have literally been that what is that Charlie conspiracy theory dude
this week you just like pointing you got the string on the on the bolted board that is that has been me
this week with CSS injection man there has been some really cool stuff popping up in CSS injection
and actually there's been some cool stuff that is like seven years old at this point that I'm just now
finding out about that is absolutely amazing so I'm excited to cover that today but first let's get to the
news the Joel with the news report so space raccoon do you want to start with that one or should we start with
yeah yeah so space raccoon has a really cool um blog post that he came out with um talking about um
well universal code execution I don't should we talk about the wording of that so so I think it's
interesting I think it's interesting because when I went into this I was like um okay you know that
sounds real real intense yeah and and as you start reading through it um first of all let me just say
it's extraordinarily well done research um as always as always classic space raccoon stuff um however
there are a lot of conditions for this for this actual exploit to be met and essentially what this
this article outlines is like some of the functionalities surrounding chrome extensions and
how um the developer documentation and some of the ways that you have to communicate with these
extensions can be um manipulated to result in code execution on the client um on the actual client
running the chrome extension in their browser um and and I think I learned a lot about chrome extension
architecture from this one and I think the way that he deals with essentially the massive amount of
conditions required for this attack is pretty awesome uh essentially using uh large data sets to query
um chrome extensions that uh fit a certain profile but man there are a lot of conditions
yeah for sure and I think it's like it's a great example of one of those sort of niche areas of research
where once you start to dig into how these things work you find a lot of really interesting
topic specific information about you know pitfalls or weird configurations or just like strange behavior
and stuff like that um and I think this is really really useful as a whole I haven't seen a whole lot
of research done about chrome extensions and I know that there's a lot of programs that own or have a
chrome extension that's in scope usually um and I think a lot of people don't really test it because
it's it's not very easy to test it's kind of falls into that weird gray area of both like web hacking
but also code analysis type stuff um so there's definitely it's very interesting and it's definitely
fringe fringe web hacking you know it's like there's javascript you know obviously heavily involved in
there but it's using a bunch of like chrome apis that's hooking it's like a combination of desktop
hacking and and uh and web hacking which I think is a really cool area and I don't know if you've seen
the content calendar yet Joel but I added some stuff on there and we do have an episode coming up soon
on chrome extension hacking which is going to be super awesome so I think this is a nice little
little intro into this do you want to do the um the the tldr for this one or or should I yeah you you go
ahead because um yeah I I did look into it pretty pretty well and essentially what he does here is he
explains uh chrome extension architecture uh and essentially there's this whole concept of a a content
script which is essentially a script that gets added to each individual page that is within the scope for
that uh chrome extension um so that you can run javascript uh and that that js code has access to the
dom but doesn't have access to like javascript variables and stuff like that on the page um and so it's sort
of living in its own little isolated world I think that's actually the technical term uh uh which is
cool um and and because of that you know there are some some limitations on on what it can do and
essentially one of the most common ways for uh people to structure these these uh content uh what do
they call to get content scripts there we go I was like wait a second what is going on here um
the these content strips is to be able to communicate with the front end via post message okay so you're
sending a post message to from this content script up to uh the browser extension uh sort of back end
the the uh post message a listener that's kind of sitting on the back end and then you're passing
through that data to other uh sort of chrome extension uh apis like for example the um the I can't get the
name of it right here it's the native um send send message the one that allows you to actually send
a message to a native application on the front end there's so many like terms and stuff that we're
just not like used to again this is like one of those weird you know it's such a niche area that has
so many um quirks just to that are specific to it yeah yeah and and so there's this I finally found
this section of the of the app here it's it's send native message and essentially what that allows
you to do from the the chrome extension back end is interface directly with a native application on the
local device so this is for stuff like um using password managers and and that sort of thing um and
essentially it just does this via standard in and out and the whole premise of his research is like
okay um if there's a way for us to interact with these content scripts and then that content script
passes the message straight through through to the back end and then passes the message straight
through to the the native message api right now we're passing uh this this data directly through
to a native application on the back end and then that native application handles um the user input
in in a bad way then uh then vulnerabilities can happen so it's like there's like a a set of like
one two three four conditions uh that must happen for this like attack chain to work and then he's like so it gets pretty
complex but here is this massive data set called the chrome extension manifest data set that you can use to
query and then here's the sem grep role and it just shows how he takes you know these set of conditions
program you know writes a program to detect these and then sprays it across the whole data set and
actually ends up finding um a vulnerability in a plugin with like what was it like two million i think
there's two million installs on it yeah uh he i don't think he mentioned what the actual one was
but he said it had two million users yeah yeah one such extension is the extension extension b quote
unquote with two million installs um which is awesome so it's really cool to see him sort of have an
idea on how this research should work and then programize it and then find things that are actually
vulnerable to it across the whole uh extension data set um and then pop some cool bugs with it very
very well yeah yeah absolutely i mean it's really like that start to finish of finding a bug figuring
out how to do it and mass and then like doing it like at scale and then reporting all that stuff and
you know it's it's really awesome to you know see a great example of that especially in a niche
research like this yeah okay so to try to be a little bit more concise and clear with my explanation
here okay the content script has a has a post message listener it takes data from that post
message listener sends it to the chrome back end via send message and then there's an insecure handling
of send message it passes it through to send native message which is now hitting a native app on the
uh on the actual device and then the native app incorrectly handles that data and introduces a
vulnerability in the system the example that he has is like a path traversal um to to
lotus a dll and essentially he forced the download of a dll because he's got control of js right in
the browser you can force the download and then uh loads that that url or that dll um from the path
traversal on the back end and gets rc so um pretty crazy chain definitely worth a read because it helps
me understand a little bit better how chrome extensions work and what kind of functionality they
have surrounding them and i think let me just add this one more thing i think the fact that he talks
about common patterns in chrome extensions is like that sort of stuff is really helpful to know because
in order to get that intuition of like what's a common pattern what's not a common pattern you have to
read through a lot of chrome extension code bases which is going to take a lot of time and
you gene saved us that time with this write-up yeah it's that sort of like meta knowledge stuff like
what's all the ways to open or to reference a window yeah exactly like that kind of research is
um it's really valuable even when it's i mean as a whole that's not really what the purpose of this
blog is but it's kind of just nested in there as a little treat which is awesome yeah a little bonus a
little bonus um all right so actually kind of a thin week as far as news goes um the only one that i
had otherwise here besides obviously all of the css injection stuff that i'm gonna freak out about uh
later later on in this episode i literally i'm sleep deprived right now because i've just been so
i was laying in bed last night and i was trying to fall asleep and i was just like my brain just kept
on churning css injection stuff what is wrong with you dude i don't know it's not even that crazy of a
vuln either it's like it's like very fringe this is like literally like leg awake at night like
restless thinking about css like i've got problems man i've got problems okay so before but before we
get to that let's cover this next one okay so um this one was just kind of uh this is a tweet from um
adithia sorry i don't know how to pronounce it and i'm i automatically put like a japanese spin on it
for some reason if it fits to japanese characters um but essentially what this person tweeted out was
uh a way to escalate client-side path reversals essentially in script tags using the uh built-in
json p callback that's a part of a wordpress websites which we've talked about probably two or
three times at this point um on the podcast so nothing super new there but it did get my brain
turning a little bit and i wanted to shoot out a prediction really quickly and and ask for the
community to do some research or at least keep their eyes peeled uh for a variant of this which is
essentially if we can find something in like wordpress or drupal or like some of these big frame or like
um for example cloudflare cdn cgi right if we could find some extras right you know on these very widely
used frameworks uh that allows us to arbitrarily control the response the json formatted response
that would be extremely helpful for exploiting client-side path reversals okay so essentially here
you know they have a json p callback you're able to specify you know what javascript function is used to
trigger the callback that's great we've talked about a million times what i want is an endpoint where
i can specify arbitrary json in the query parameter and it returns that that json in the response should
just just reflects it right down into the response and the reason why that's extremely helpful is that
if you have a client-side path driver so obviously um you're controlling where that api request is being
sent to um and you but it is expecting the same some data format back because it thinks it's communicating
with the same api endpoint that it's always you know always communicated with so what you what essentially
needs to happen is we need to find a way for it to give it the data format that it expects in json as
as a response and then we can use that to trigger xss you know business logic bugs open redirects like
these are all cases that i've seen um when you're able to actually control that arbitrary json response
and normally my my go-to way to do this joel is i i redirect off the domain to my domain right and then
i control the json response but that requires an open redirect and if we can find a gadget in like
wordpress or something like that that allows us to do this then uh we wouldn't have to redirect off
domain we would we would just be able to do it with like a semi-open redirect um or even a closed
redirect the domain or even some sort of browser specific feature like i know there's some really
interesting research recently that i've seen about blobs like uh like those like ephemeral sort of uh file
blob things that are in the browser um and you can like reference them and technically the origin is
actually wherever they came from so like if you have a blob that was created on example.com and you're
referencing like you have an xss in that blob for example the origin or like you know domain
um like window.domain um or document.domain is going to be the host that the blob was created on oh really so
i i don't know if it has access to cookies and all that kind of stuff i think there's some like
weird limitations around that but yeah potentially also something like that where you have some sort
of browser specific feature that would allow you to control the file contents yeah that would be
an interesting attack vector that would be really cool blobs i think have a a custom scheme that's
associated with yes it's like blob colon http yeah so so i i'm wondering whether in these scenarios in
these client-side path reversal like scenarios whether we could hit those maybe if there's like a redirect
that was doing some domain level validation but wasn't checking the scheme or something like that
then you could definitely have something like that happen but i like i like the way you're thinking joel
thinking outside the box some critical thinking thinking like a hacker aren't you think i'm thinking
like a hacker hey where did i get this shirt critical critical critical i love how i'm like uh obsessing over
over client-side path to read uh css injection and client-side patch for so lately and this is
you know these almost are never critical critical criticals you know yeah almost ever we gotta we
gotta start talking about critical critical criticals um uh well actually i guess on that note on that note
i will take a tangent on something that is not here in the doc joel which is that um i'm giving a talk at
defcon this year that i was also frantically preparing last night for the deadline that was
last night um uh surrounding like some of the coolest critical reports that i've found over the
past couple years of bug bounty so there's 11 bugs in there all of them are criticals um critical critical
criticals and uh and so if you're interested in hearing a bunch of bug stories uh about about those
definitely check out uh bug bounty village talk that i'll be doing at defcon i think it's in title
i don't even know the title off the top of my head i think it's like top war stories from a try
hard bug bounty hunter or something like that so beyond the law for that self-assisted self-promotion
shameless self-promotion did you have to complete your slides like fully yeah dude yeah i did whoa which
is like a pain because it's like a month in advance and it makes sense because they've got a lot of
stuff to recover or to uh to cover and and you know assess but um man it it was a lot yeah it's
like 150 slides i mean especially this far in advance that's a that's a ton yeah i think we can
make small modifications to it between now and then but essentially they said it needs to be like
as finalized as possible wow okay well that's pretty no no procrastinating allowed yeah apparently not
yeah cool all right let's uh you want to talk about your your special critical thinkers release
and then we'll yeah okay cool so yesterday very exciting yesterday i dropped passion project of
mine that uh i've been working on for the past couple weeks that i just kind of bulldozed my whole
schedule and worked on this because i had the motivation and that is essentially a full-time bug
bounty blueprint how to go full-time on bug bounty it's like a 15 page document describing essentially
if i were having a personal conversation with you and you were saying i want to go full-time bug bounty
what should i do this is what i would say to you at length um so it's very conversationally written
it covers a lot of topics sort of ranging from um what kind of difficulties you're going to face as a
full-time bug bounty hunter what kind of um like personality traits uh or um i guess like motivation
uh deficits you might uh come up against that that are going to cause problems um we cover taxes we
cover um like all the good stuff yeah like how how to how to collaborate with other hackers how to quit
your job and in transition into full-time bug bounty how to make sure you your finances are squared in
advance um and then essentially how to build a pipeline surrounding you know your bug bounty skills
and keep on driving that stuff in to create a good consistent income stream for you that you can live
off of so um it's it's not to toot my own horn here it's pretty good i think it's really good and and the
feedback has been positive so um definitely check that out if you're interested critical thinkers um if
you're not a critical thinker head over to discord check out the server subscriptions that we've got
there um this book is only available to the critical thinkers um so even if you want you know go ahead
drop a sub it's 25 bucks for one month grab the book and bounce that's fine too but uh in that one
month i think you'll find critical thinkers tier is something special man there's a lot of great
conversations happening in that in that uh in that sort of exclusive discord channel and a lot of cool
um a lot of cool scripts a lot of cool techniques good conversations happening in there so check it out if
you haven't already yeah absolutely exclusive master glasses and stuff too all yeah all we do
master glasses at least once a month um or hack alongs too um and we record all of them we put them all in
in there so you know store you you know you have months of back content that you get access to and so
lots of really cool features if you want to go check it out yeah absolutely um oh yeah one other cool
feature that is actually um in the the critical thinkers exclusive content channel that i wanted to just kind of
shout out um is the client-side path traversal browser extension that uh me and in bus factor
wrote um bus factor is a a very valued member of the critical thinking uh community and we were just
kind of discussing what it would look like to build a browser extension for client-side path traversal
and i like threw some kind of junk code at him i was like this is kind of roughly how it would work
and i come back the next day and he's like converted it all to typescript and like has a build flow
and like all these nice little buttons and stuff like that and i'm like oh man this this rocks so i
kind of took it from there as well and did some additional modifications for it but at this point
it's pretty good it detects pretty consistently um when you have data reflected from uh you know the
query parameters the hash a couple other areas into the path of a sub resource you know request whether
it be like an iframe or a fetch or something like that um those are things that we all want to know about
so we have that extension available um to the critical thinkers as well and i think probably
at some point we'll we'll release it probably within the next year or so but i definitely want to refine
it a little bit and uh get it to a spot where you know some of the the difficulties are ironed out some
of the false positives are ironed out um before we release it full-time yeah i definitely have a couple
really good plugin ideas in the in the pipeline i think i know we've talked about a variety of different
things um some of them we may have even cut out of yeah the recording so um yeah we'll we'll definitely
be creating those and releasing those eventually uh to the community as we go just for our own
purposes and also just to share the share the knowledge with the critical thinkers but yeah yeah
no absolutely hey guys real quick i just wanted to give a shout to the hacker content team they have
been absolutely killing it the past couple months taking the content from the podcast and condensing it
down into consumable social media posts whether it be shorts or text posts or whatever they've been
rocking it so i just wanted to give them a shout out and let you know that they do all sorts of
cyber security content as well as social media management they do technical blogs they do uh
comprehensive social media management uh so if your organization could benefit from any of those
types of services make sure you head over to hackercontent.com drop them a line and mention the
podcast when you do to get your first month of cyber security content marketing services for free
all right that's it let's get back to the pod all right man the moment has come css injection time
your your moment my mom unfold the the conspiracy theory all right man here's here's what i got okay
so i didn't know until last week that css injection has been pretty much completely solved prior to this i
thought that essentially we had a really reliable way to leak the contents of like attributes and
that sort of thing but um actually it is possible to leak the content of a text node as well right
just the inner html or whatever of a specific element if that's text um does it require user interaction
so i mean of course the user has to navigate to the thing but once they navigate as long as you can do an
import um from a remote uh css page i guess then you're good to go um and you can block that with
csp right yes you can so if we're talking about remediation methods csp is pretty much the the best
way to do this uh obviously besides like not introducing the vulnerability in the first place
which i think is not too hard to do with css injection like you need a pretty niche scenario
um for css injection to happen in the first place but i guess should follow most of the same like
instances of any other type of xss or html injection right where you're just some sort of content is
making its way unsanitized into the the response body so in the same way that you would sanitize any
of the rest of those you'd probably fix that as well right yeah exactly but we don't need to dwell on
how to fix it joel we need to dwell on how to exploit it okay just some of us do take your
program managers away from me okay like we don't need that right now this is this is my moment um
okay so there there are two things that i kind of want to talk about today and give the listeners a tldr
on essentially what csp injection has to offer and like how to actually exploit it okay so first one is
of course the one that i think most people are familiar with this is the one that i was using um to
exploit csp injection uh up until this point which is essentially the research done by uh
uh donut doing using sequential um import chaining and it's just back from like singapore right so
it was that the was it that event i don't know when he originally came out or something i remember
it was a long it was a while ago yeah free code no yeah it absolutely was and and uh it's been i mean
it's been out for a long time at this point but essentially this is the whole concept of like
you have a css import statement right you've got that like at import feature with with css and you
import a remote style sheet and that style sheet includes another remote style sheet and does some css
rule that will trigger a callback right and what what will happen is you don't on the server side you
don't respond to that second style sheet import until you've gotten the call back from the first
uh set of rules that you put in there to leak the first character or whatever right once you've done
that once you've got that first character leaked then you respond and you do the same thing recursively
until you have leaked the whole content of like a uh an hdm attribute and the whole point the whole
reason why this is possible is because you can use the the starts with um selector for for css stuff
so essentially you're doing a carrot equal sign and then you know whatever value and and you're able to
specify okay uh if the attribute starts with this then you know trigger this http request file like
background image or whatever um and it since you're able to do that you can just by character by character
by character by character just brute force out um the value of these attributes which is which is super
cool um and has been absolutely uh very very relevant and very much used in in the in the uh community for
css injection and it was what i was using up until this point to prove most of my impact um so this this
was and just to be clear this was um released by donut and uh another guy pepe villa at the exact same same
time around 2019 range um and so that is a well-established technique you knew all that right joel oh yeah
yeah of course all that yeah because i know how much you love css injection and all these little
fringe web web yeah but in on the dark and they call me the css injection master
you thanks for that thanks for that man okay so um cool so i went in the rabbit hole this week
because of some other things that i'll mention later but while i was in that rabbit hole um i i found a
little bit more research on this specific technique that i didn't know about before so i wanted to share
it with the community which is um this technique it's pretty fast uh i think it only takes like a couple
seconds to to maybe 10 seconds or so to leak a decent sized token but um you can double the speed
of it by also simultaneously selecting from the back side of of the the um attribute the html
attribute that you're trying to suddenly became a computer science leak code problem right so so it's
like you know you're forcing the characters you're coming in you're coming in and eventually you're
converging somewhere right um and i thought that was really interesting it doubles the speed and it
makes a little sense why that would why that would work um so cool little little addition there um
that's awesome the the other thing that i wanted to kind of shout out in the same like leaking
attributes section is this uh repo by um port swigger research called css exfiltration which i think
was a repo that was related to like some write-up they did back in 2020 i believe um and this was
like recent gareth hayes research right so this was not the blog or the exfiltration thing was i mean
so recently um gareth hayes came out with a a blog post on blind uh css exfiltration and this was one
of the things that like kind of triggered me uh a while back back into css injection um very cool project
i think we've talked about it once or twice before in the pod if not just google blind css exfiltration
it's literally the only article on it out there because what talk about a fringe uh piece of
security research like that is the epitome of fringe um but this is actually something different joel
this is some research that he had done years before and it's really it's really interesting
because this repo contains like one two three four five six like over 10 different techniques for leaking
um characters from different contexts uh via css injection so he's got like steel and characters
in firefox steel reverse firefoxed steel script contents like all of these very like a mon shazer
seriously man it's like he's got a bunch of really cool ways of doing this and one of the ones that kind
of stood out to me and i was like oh man i didn't know that was possible was that um you can steal the
contents of an attribute by using the attr function in css okay check this out joel i'm gonna i'm gonna
link it to you in because i don't think i put it like super clearly in the doc i'm gonna know you are in
css yeah so click that link that i just sent you in discord okay so online online five we'll drop this
in the description um uh on line five there is a essentially a um a content css attribute that is defined
uh defining a property in css and the value of that content so the content is of course used to add
like a prefix or post fix to a specific div or whatever the content of that is attr function call
and then the name of the attribute and essentially what that will do is set the in this scenario the
after content so the content that comes after this div uh to be this value of a specific attribute right
and then you can you can style that after attribute with a specific font that will exfiltrate all the
data from that so this whole like attr um function in css i think is really fascinating that you can
access html attributes and stick their content into the the content property in css pretty yeah i'm
curious i'm curious how far that extends because i know that there are certain like weird things like
doesn't dot value like implicitly um contain like whatever you've put into like a for like a form
input for example right it's like would the value attribute from css on a form input contain that
value or would it be would have to be explicitly said i don't know you know it's funny you mentioned
dot value because that dot value is a little weird right i feel like there are some frameworks that will
like automatically update the dot value or like essentially the value html attribute and i know that if you
use like in javascript if you use dot value that it it just dumps the content of a like an input field
or something like that but i think sometimes it doesn't update it um for things like html and css it
just does it in the javascript context so that's an interesting question i'm not i'm not sure the answer
to that one yeah yeah but i'd be curious to see if there's other you know weird cases like that or any
implicit attributes or anything like that like that exists but isn't you know visible all the time stuff
like that you're starting to feel it right jol like this is interesting right it's super weird i'm
i mean it makes you wonder like why does something like that exist i don't i don't know i'm sure
there's some use case and there's probably some other weird edge case stuff that exists just like it
well css injection or css in general is just getting stronger and stronger and stronger right as they
introduce new new features so that's one of the things that i like really keep an eye out for in in the
browser um change logs is like what features are they adding to css and how does that affect our current
understanding of css and i was a lot more motivated to do this when i thought that text node content so
essentially if you have something in like let's say inside an h1 tag you want to leak like you know hi
joel or something like that you want to leak the person's name um i thought that was not solved but
that actually is solved which is crazy to me um so now i'm a little bit less motivated to be honest
this has been a little bit demotivating this whole research uh thing that i've been on it's like oh
well they figured it all out um but now you know yes yes now i know um and and so uh okay before
before we get too far down that down that path i'm gonna go ahead and paste this uh this link a link
that i was talking about in the doc see you know many other podcasts other youtubers even they forget
to put the links in the description you have always a critical thinking not us we don't forget we don't
forget unless it's a master class that i wrote or i ran and then it takes me a week of forgetting
what are you doing i did it though oh man all right so css selectors to leak the contents of html
attributes boom done of course that's that's done that's been done for a while but the problem is
nowadays we have uh single page applications that are pretty much everywhere right um and they don't
often have input fields with pre-populated values like c surf token or like api token or something
like that oftentimes that gets stuck inside of a script text node right uh and just populated directly
into javascript as a part of like those i don't know what do they call it's like like seed data almost
for the page it's like a json blob like the state or whatever yeah like state but yeah exactly the the
state like json blob right that's where all the juicy stuff is nowadays um and that's why
this research is so crazy which by the way is so awesome when you find like a single xss because then
you just have one giant json that's included on every page exactly just like your token and all the
config parameters it's so nice yeah exactly exactly love that and we can now we can do that also with um
with css injection okay and the way we do this is via this crazy absolutely nuts technique that i'm just
i love i always know what justin puts a tweet in the doc that is just written entirely in japanese and
is like three days old that's gonna be some crazy crazy research that he's about to try so masato kinagawa
does some amazing amazing research man uh and so lately what he's been up to which triggered this whole
thing was he tweeted out in japanese about um some of the uh research he's been doing on font ligatures
and how he's been applying that to lava moat which is a an absolutely or lava dome in particular lava
mode i think is the company above it so so check out this this product joel it's like a little bit
further down in the doc but like essentially this product lava dome is a a dom element isolator so
essentially you can have a a piece of the dom that you just cannot get the value from from javascript
you can have xss and you just won't be able to like get the value out of this uh this piece of the
dom um why not well they isolate it out they do a bunch of um just crazy stuff to to block in native
javascript yeah yeah so like you literally can't get it and there's a bunch of conditions to it right so
if you if you go to the lava dome javascript uh we believe this is a solvable problem is that yeah
pretty crazy right that they could they think they can actually isolate a node from the rest of the dom
and you just can't touch it and they call it like you know shadow dom use case is a feature for metamask
show private key toggle which exposes the private key in plain text currently the sensitive content is
attached to the dom once it's exported making it fully accessible to all nc's running right so they're
saying we believe this is the whole problem the whole concept of this project is is um quote we
live in a world where we can no longer trust the code in our own apps and same origin execution does
not guarantee safety and i'm like okay all right let's go and and um it's amazing because they're
essentially trying to protect the value of some you know html inner text from themselves which is like
a very difficult problem to solve and i can just like the moment that masato kinugawa started looking
at this project like it's over man because there's a bunch of like issues in this project that he has
submitted like leaking the values of of uh you know lava dome via character height and font ligatures and
mouse over and text fragments and like there's just a bunch of crazy ways that he's done it um but
overall i mean very interesting project and i think most of the time the approach like they mentioned
in their in their readme is to actually put that sensitive content in an isolated iframe um but
apparently they say you know you could put in an isolated iframe but that doesn't feel as cool or
something like that and why don't you put it in lava dome instead which is like okay
uh yeah yeah okay and then and then masato kinugawa is like no no no i will not allow for this um
so essentially he's tweeting out about all of these different ways to steal it and and one of the ones
that he he tweeted out was very much related to css injection which is essentially like you can use
um font ligatures uh to to leak the content of this of this uh you know sort of encapsulated dom okay
yeah do you know what a font ligature is joel i do know what a font ligature is why do you know what a
font ligature is because i use font ligatures what yeah so okay so of course you do of course you know
about this tldr here is that my my the the terminal setup that i use it uses a font that uses ligatures
specifically in both vs code and iterm to convert like double equals into a fancy thing or triple
equals into a fancy character or equals right arrow to a fancy arrow and that kind of stuff so
do you know here what i'll let you dude i won't take you i won't say your moment i won't say this
this is like the most of course this is joel moment that i can possibly think of it's like
there's some super awesome you know niche piece of technology that i'm ready to blow your mind
about and you're like oh yeah i use that for my terminal or like the most like random thing exactly
like just like absolute tech enthusiast shit you could possibly think of um that's hilarious dude
okay so font ligatures essentially what this what this allows you to do is when you have a custom font
you can specify a sequence of characters that has a a custom glyph so glyph being the the sort of actual
um visual representation of the character yeah so essentially what you can do um is you can define
any length of of uh font ligature so you can have a font ligature that's like 35 characters long or more
right where if it sees this 35 character sequence it displays it with a separate gif gif it does not
display a gift glyph glyph thank you all of a sudden you start typing and then all like the the conspiracy
charlie pops up or whatever oh man it's so good um so anyway you can define these these uh special um
ligatures and this allows you to actually leak the content of a text node so very similar to what
we're you're doing with the css selectors essentially you can have it you can load up a custom font on
into this specific text node and then um that font has these ligatures and if um everything else every
other character a through z you know zero through nine that sort of thing is set to a zero width character
you can control the width of of the the characters in the font um the custom font creation process
but the ligature that you're trying to leak is massive you know it's like 10 000 pixels or something
like that wide okay and then you style the container that this text is in such that if um if it's above a
certain length there is a uh or above a certain width there is a scroll bar that appears right so that
can give you a binary yes or no on whether this uh ligature is actually created or not right um
because when the scroll bar appears you can style the scroll bar to have a background image that will
reach back out to your server right okay i like how that works you see what i'm doing here with the
the shadow dom yeah shadow down by the way that's a whole rabbit hole too i'd never heard of that and
it's just like yeah is that what you've been doing for the past couple minutes while i've been explaining
this joel i was i was in the beginning but i am paying attention i'm paying attention all right i
i could see the the classic moment when joel says shadow dom that sounds either it sounds interesting
in so many ways um so anyway font ligatures super cool essentially um what you have to do to to make
this whole this whole process work is you've got to set up a uh recursive um css import like we were
talking about in the beginning um a la donut and pepe villa um and what it just sounds like a meme i
don't like pepe villa like i mean am i saying the name you sound like twitchy boats it does sort of like
oh because it's like i am saying the the name right right oh geez that's gonna be sorry mr villa if i am not
saying it it right no i mean yeah i mean that's the name so wow you just made fun of this guy's name
and his and his amazing research on on css it's a cool name i just it is it was the cadence i don't
know maybe maybe it was the cadence okay so anyway you use the recursive import i'm just going to call
it donuts research via donuts research there right and just like i'm not going to risk trigger him again
his name his name has been erased because of your your tendencies joel um uh and so you're
essentially recursively importing these these style sheets you're waiting for the callback before you
respond to the next one and essentially each time you're forcing the style sheet to load up a new font
which you are dynamically generating to have ligatures which are expanding with each character that has been
leaked um and the way that the character is leaked is by a uh essentially a boolean of um
has the scroll bar appeared or or not um and so here's where which is detected by the background
url on that scroll bar exactly exactly but it here's the here's the thing that i'm thinking
can be optimized a little bit okay we can use animations to change values of css over time so
we can say like all right now it's this font now it's this font now it's this font without having to
do a network request except for the font of course um so i i think that would be that would be really
interesting and i think since it's a a you know sort of a boolean yes or no you kind of have to load
each character until you get a hit right so is it an a no okay next one is it a b yes no you know is it
is it a c you know that sort of thing right and i'm wondering if essentially we could reduce the
complexity of doing this this search by creating fonts that have ligatures that essentially do a binary
search on the possible character set so it's gonna have it's gonna have a wide length if any of the
following characters uh appear in the sequence and it's gonna have and it's gonna not if the other
half and then you're halving it each time right so if you're dealing with like a 256 you know standard
ascii character set or whatever which i think there's less displayable characters but whatever then
you know you need a maximum of like seven or eight requests um to brute force a character which is
like not that bad um okay hear me out on this hear me out okay i've been i've been brainstorming okay
i've been thinking i've been thinking oh joel's using his brain careful uh okay i kind of need you to
help me with this dude because i was trying to apply it apply it yesterday and it's just kind of
blowing my mind so maybe so i was just thinking like i was thinking about fonts as a whole because i know
there's been like very niche research about like using fonts in this way as like basically kind of
like um like a blind injection where like it's uh it's it's you have some sort of other signal um
that you're reading um as like a canary to figure out whether or not this is working or it's not working
sure and are you talking about the unicode code point stuff well if you define a custom font i mean
you can make those characters larger or smaller like you can you can change how they render and
and like what they display as so if you can get a custom font in the page at all um and you just
change the font of everything i'm wondering if there's some way where you could basically have
each character be a different size so that you could just take the width of an entire element and
then you start to subtract and you go okay um can i subtract 26 from this all right well there's a z in
it uh can i subtract 25 from this there's a you know a y in it or whatever like something like
that where you could basically uh do some binary math or some sort of um derivation off of the total
width based on the unique widths of each character within the character set yeah and then figure out
what's in it without having to also yeah see dude see this is great i need to nerd snipe you on this
because i know that there's something like that is possible and that's what i've been that's what i was
thinking about last night when i was sitting in bed it looked staring at the ceiling like
how and essentially the problem then becomes how do you determine remotely what the width and height
of a character of like a specific div is um while still doing some semblance of word wrapping so that
you can control the number of characters that you're applying this to which gets really tricky in the css world
is like okay wrapping is highly correlated to the width of the element and so like it the css properties
just don't like to work together in such a way that you can isolate the characters so that you can
detect how wide the actual um thing is and and or the actual container is and expand it in such a way
that you're like okay there's three there's three characters in here now there's four all right now i can
look at the you know the width and the difference in width or the difference in height uh like like
masato kinogawa does um in other spots in this research um and it's it becomes a tricky problem and
and and the cool thing about the lava dome thing is essentially what he's able to do is check that height
and width via javascript because you have javascript execution right so essentially he's using the style
width and style height um properties this is in a different um bypass to lava dome than the one
we're talking about or lava moat lava dome all right i've got you one i've got you i've got you a
potential thing here oh my gosh you're not listening to anything i'm saying you're researching stuff
there's a css selector called first line are you aware of this one yes i'm aware of it i've been using
it all the time that's exactly what i'm talking about the problem is is it's difficult to to get the
right amount of characters on the first line right and that first line selector is like absolutely
revolutionary you have to use that um in a bunch of css selection techniques but getting the correct
characters to like bump onto that first line and then be able to tell the width is is tricky man it's
tricky well we'll we'll do some research together after this episode and then maybe we can come back
in and present it but i'm i'm running into some difficulties getting all this stuff to work
yeah i think i think i'll have to check
there because there are a lot of different um css like measurement selectors you know what i mean like p
px yeah um there's one c there's one called ch yeah that's the character how many characters are on
the line yes yes you're getting it joel you're seeing you're seeing the the craziness that is the css
injection world right so you can you can set a specific amount of characters to be on a line
and then on that then measure the length of that line right and you should be able to determine and
the change to the width of that line should be able to tell you the value that was added right but
it's not that you can do math and css too like you can multiply and stuff did you know maybe maybe it
is that simple i don't know there's a calc function i've i've got like 17 asked if one asked if two
asked if three dot html files with lots of different css in them that i'd like to show you break word too
yes okay see joel this is why you need to go and read the exploits that i put into the dock before
the episode because all of these things that you're discovering are in the dock um yeah no triggered man
um okay so let me get back and actually add some value to listener really quick okay instead of you
and me just doing our exploitation flow like we always do um the thing that you need to know
in order to do html attribute exfiltration you use the sequential import training from donut and you use
um the css selectors from the front and from the back to make it super fast right or you can just use
donuts tool does that very well established battle tested boom easy peasy to leak text nodes is a little
bit more difficult i don't know if i'm going to get it done in time by the uh the time that this episode
airs but i'm trying to get a pretty cool tool in place that will essentially be the equivalent of
donuts um sequential import training tool um but for leaking the value of text nodes via dynamic uh
ligature generation um and that sort of thing and there are some poc codes out there uh by uh michael
bentowski who's the guy that came up with this original research back in 2017 um and very like
very sketchy poc code you know it's like just very you know he just finished it and put it up and it's
great and it gets the the the details across but i'm trying to get something that is you know battle
tested that it's pretty applicable you just essentially import a css um style sheet and
you specify the query selector for the text node that you want and it just dumps out the content
of that text node so i'm gonna work on it i'm not sure if i'm gonna get there but in the meantime if
you need to actually um leak the contents of a text node uh the research by uh michael bentowski um
uh linked in the description i got you uh will be very helpful for that and does show a basic poc of
how you can dynamically generate these ligatures over time to leak the full value of uh of a text
note you know i'm thinking we might just have to start uh publishing some research blog posts on uh
you know on our website but see here's the thing man we just get on the on the pod and then we yap
about it right and and that saves us the time of having to write it all up because i'll tell you
man i've been writing these presentations for the past like week i don't know and and the you know
i wrote the 15 page don't you love writing you know isn't it great i there there are little pieces of
time in which i enjoy writing right like like writing the the um the blueprint on how to go full-time
book bounty super enjoyed that busted it out pretty quickly you know really loved it but actually taking
the super brainy stuff that is css injection and trying to break it down and like put it into an
article that has that's easy for people to follow is tricky and it's i mean it's tricky to even talk
about it on the podcast so but it's really difficult yeah i i do agree though i think there is definitely
some merit to producing some sort of you know research papers or or essentially uh write-ups and
having it in the text medium obviously brandon is doing a good job of converting everything that we
say in the podcast into the the hacker notes and that sort of thing but i think we're trying to
get a little bit more in depth on these sort of things i mean just unique research more yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah um so anyway that that font ligature piece the scroll bar generation that stuff
is really cool um definitely check that out but here here is the the thing that really sparked this
whole thing again right which is um masato kinugawa essentially submitted a um issue to lava dome
using a new um css property that i hadn't seen before called descent override uh which allows you to
change the height of each individual character um in in a font face definition right so you're defining a
custom font you define a custom code point right you can do the unicode code point for that specific
font um and say all right this font only applies to like the a character or whatever and then make
the a character super big right super massive and whenever that character gets typed into the
or typed or appears in the um the dom then it you know the size inflates drastically um and so
essentially he's able to do all of this this definition without actually using a custom font he
uses i think just comic sans um and then this override for the height to leak the content of um the
the lava dome value by changing or by detecting changes to the height like we were talking about
he has access to javascript so he can do that if if you don't have access to javascript it's really
tricky to do that but the the revolutionary piece about this is that it doesn't require a font a
custom font to be imported so you can do this in a scenario where font source is set to something
strict in the csp um really cool technique i love the fact that this descent override property exists
and allows us to control the there's another one for width as well allows us to granularly control
the width and the height for a specific character in a font face definition very interesting and if
you look through actually um the font face docs um for like the font face rule or whatever like
how it gets defined as a custom font face um there's a ton of different descriptors that exist and
there's a lot more that i think also would be great candidates for this sort of again this canary
behavior um there's font display which determines how a font face is displayed and whether or not
it gets downloaded and shown and it can behave as a fallback for example so what i'm thinking here
is like you have a default font face and then you have your custom font face that has characters that
are either invisible or by default um not visible or different widths and then it would fall back if
there's no character shown or something like that um or or have something that renders slowly um
there's something like that i don't know i think there's definitely a lot of really interesting
candidates in here there's um size adjust that might be the width one you were talking about
um there's font stretch um there's descent and ascent yeah as well that's the ones those are the ones that
that he uses to control the the height and width of the yeah yeah very size adjust so yeah there's a
lot of different things and you know we've talked about this so many times we've gone through the dot
the like the web or whatever html docs so many times that we found like weird consistencies or even
inconsistencies things that are in the doc that do not behave that way at all in the browser right
being of the base tag um so just because it says that this is how something works doesn't necessarily
mean that this sounds this is how this works but if it says that this is how it works that's also a
great starting point this is weird yeah this is weird dude you you just you just uh nerds
sniped me with this now i'm looking through all these different properties there there's gotta be
stuff here man this is this is exactly maybe there's some way we can use shazer here too by the way
like um to to fuzz this stuff in mass or like try all the possible options and and figure out what
the different permutations and and possible um selectors and descriptors and stuff that you can use
here yeah absolutely okay so let me let me add one more thing to this okay so um of course for
the content of the text node it has to be displaying that text right for the font to be loaded and and
for it to trigger and for us to be able to do the whole ligature dance or whatever right here's something
crazy that i didn't know joel okay you can apply display block to a script tag and then all of a
sudden the script tag the content like the actual content of the script tag the javascript will just
be displayed on the screen like it was like a like a like a p tag isn't that crazy it makes you wonder
what other i didn't know like what happens if you put it on a video tag or an audio tag or a iframe or
or or um well i think oh geez what was i just thinking of uh a lot of those would just you know
display the actual you know feature but the the crazy thing to me about this is like i don't know i just
didn't think of the style tag yeah right i just didn't think that the contents of a script tag
i didn't think of it as like a text node but but it is text you know it's inside of a of a script tag so
if you just apply it you wonder a little bit about the order of operations as well around like
it probably gets evaluated and then like css gets applied later just sees it as like an element or
something but then does that apply to like can you do that to the head tag or like what you know like
what where does that end right yeah yeah and and i'm sure there's lots of other you know weird niche
cases with this but the reason why the script tag is so big is is just like we were talking about
before is like there's these there are these uh you know blobs of json the the window.state or whatever
and they're normally you know prefixed by the same thing right window.state equals and then big massive
blob right that is a dream come true for this sort of text-based um uh data exfiltration piece right
because essentially when you define a prefix you eliminate a bunch of like uh variants like if if a
b appears in like six different spots in the whole you know uh script blob then you could have some
problems but um you know if you have a prefix that only appears once then that really helps so
uh setting you know display block to a specific script tag and then using these font ligatures to
extract things like uh pii api tokens uh c surf tokens all those sort of things um really awesome way to
to exploit css injection and i'm kind of salty because i've had css injections and i put so much
research into css injections and i totally did not know about this technique and you're gonna hate me
because i just found more stuff but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna derail you i'm gonna send it i'll
send it just send it to me man we'll we'll review it and then maybe i can find no don't send it to me
right now joel what are you i'm trying to to podcast here man um okay very interesting so um display block
can actually display a script tag and then you use the text node based um font ligature based uh recursive
import based leak method to actually leak your contents of your of your text node which will
result in hopefully account takeover or at least c surf uh or i guess at at minimal pii leakage in
most applications so um very cool stuff there um i know i had one other thing that i wanted to talk
about with this uh before we we call it your cat is very distracting right now she's she wants attention
she does she does um oh i did want to shout out two blogs okay that were kind of um helpful with this
and i will shout those out right after i mentioned one other piece okay so the tweet that i saw that you
mentioned that was just all in japanese and was from masatsu kinugawa was essentially his research on
font ligatures and how they are affected by um the before a pseudo attribute was it pseudo pseudo class
essentially the thing that allows you to add text before a certain text blob right or a certain text
node and essentially what he did is um there's there's this japanese word kabushiki guys shop and that
that's like uh like for if we were going to put it in english it's like um limited liability company
or something right that like that right and and it's got you know it has to be at the end of like
all of these like names and stuff like that um and it's got a specific ligature for it right where
they kind of put it in a square rather than to have it all typed out and so what he shows in this tweet
is that um you can actually use the before attribute the before and in content css features to trigger
these font ligatures sequences so let's say like you've got a font ligature that requires four
characters um and you have three of the characters but then you put the the first character in the css
before um uh before content uh you add it to the text node with before content um that will actually
trigger the the font ligature to occur and it will be converted into a uh you know that single um glyph
even though it's broken up by elements even though it's broken up even even though the actual text
node content only contains three of the four characters needed you can add that character with
um the before content uh feature in css um very interesting and so i thought that was really
interesting research and it only affects some browsers um so i'm going to link this tweet uh in the in
the description as well um very very interesting piece and i think this could also be used in a scenario
where you want to add sort of like you want to start um you want to start brute forcing from the very
beginning of a text node and there could be overlap with other things at other places in the in the
actual um text node itself so you kind of got to figure out how to get it just at the beginning
and essentially you could use this before attribute to prepend something that's not actually in the
character set right like a squiggly line or something like that and say okay the the font
ligature is squiggly line a squiggly line b and since squiggly line isn't going to be anywhere else in
that text node then you know you're reinforcing right from the beginning and it can increase some
uh reliability and consistency to the to the uh font ligature based css exfiltration techniques yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely are you just are you laughing at my cat no no no your cat is adorable i'm
laughing at myself uh saying like font ligature based css injection explicit like it's just so
so mega niche man it's just like man this is the epitome of of uh of nerdiness
all right man i think that i mean there's just so many other interesting pieces to talk about here but
i think that was mostly uh everything that you need to know about essentially how to exploit modern day css
injections right you use the research from donut on um uh sequential import chaining plus the the css
selectors on attributes to leak attribute values and then use this font ligature based stuff to actually
leak the value of text nodes um which is really good and if all of this doesn't make sense uh via the audio
medium uh which i would be very surprised if it did because this is very complex stuff um i would
encourage you to do additional research on how exactly all of this works uh by checking out these
two blogs okay so uh let me just let me just format my notes a little bit here so that uh we can know
exactly what two blogs i'm i'm talking about um the first one is uh man why do these have to be so named so
weird one of them is x-c3ll.github.io and essentially this is a a post on css injection primitives that
goes back to 2019 and it essentially talks about all of the different techniques you can use um in a css
injection talking about recursive imports talking about um uh text node exfiltration via ligatures
talking about html attribute exfiltration this blog post kind of is similar to what i just described
uh in this in this episode regarding all of these primitives that you can use to do css exfiltration
um so that's the first one definitely check that one out and then the other one is this blog that i
haven't heard of before um that i've never seen before and it's by this guy who is a a develop who
who calls himself a developer with security interests right and essentially if you go and look at the
blog he was a part of some writing competition in taiwan or something where he had to write like a blog
post every day for 30 days and so what he chooses is just like get to the most like technical css injection
xss breakdowns css injection breakdowns and it's really freaking quality stuff um so random so this
this blog post really made it a lot easier for me to understand the whole um font height difference
plus first line plus scroll bar technique which masato used in one of those things in conjunction with the
descent override to actually leak um the the characters um character by character um and he's got a really
great um description of that whole technique so if the whole height height width difference thing
doesn't make sense to you then i'd recommend this blog uh beyond xss exploring the front web front end
security universe um at a s z x 87410.github.io ah you're welcome for reading that out so memorable yes just super
memorable um so yeah that's where to get the additional research on um on css injection and
joel hopefully you and i can sit down after this episode and kind of hash out some of these things
because i would really like to put a server out there ideally a server that we could actually just
do it for everybody but at minimal uh a github repo that essentially allows you to just do essentially
what port swigger research did with uh blind css exfiltration where you essentially just have
one url that you import and it just dumps everything um for a given query selector or something like that
i think that'd be really helpful so yeah for sure yeah so keep an eye out in the critical thinking
discord for me trying to drop that and uh and i'm not sure i'll get to it this week because i got a
bunch of stuff i gotta prep for defcon and stuff like that but i will get to it eventually or else i
won't sleep so eventually all right man anything else you want to add here at the end i think that's it
dude this is uh this has been a really interesting one i got a lot of i got a lot of follow-up a lot
of nerds ideas yeah i got oh god i just deleted some things from the doc and on that note before
i delete the entire content of this episode yeah on the episode where we're like it will actually be in
the description too just delete all the notes all right man that's the pod right that's the pod all right
peace guys and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for listening and
if you want more critical thinking content head over to ctvb.show slash discord join the discord
there's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there and if you want to support the show
there's the discord subscriber tiers which give you access to master classes amas hack alongs
exclusive scripts and an exclusive chat channel with us we'll see you there